never started like this you sure okay
this is just pointy see all right I
think we're biology so you guys haven't
heard
we just hit 300k so I figured we would
give you guys a live stream where we
answer your questions because every time
we do a stream we never answer your
questions so cheers Cheers you know it's
actually one of my goals for this year
what's your goal for this channel to hit
1 million that would be great yeah I
know three hundreds already a big thing
and also I'm grateful but a million is
good no I mean I understand it's you
yeah I mean a million just a nice number
there's a great like me growing up a
million was a big thing if you get a
million dollars no you said four live
billion was yeah it was the like a
billion was not even think about that
yeah a million was like yeah that's big
that's big
yeah yeah I agree with that so we're
here with 300k and we will be taking
your questions so why don't we pick one
preach how tall are you 510 your
question I remember another thing you
see the difference between me like a
benign alright we're not there's not
that much of a difference but if I would
go on tinder and I'm right on five 10
I'd get a lot less woman then table here
that is six which like she is sounds way
taller but it really is and there's that
much difference I'm down with you know
five ten for women like they go for that
they don't know as long as you don't
seem divided five there's a lot of
people that just stand there the six
yeah I know you say yeah I'm six feet
tall so there you go so that's that
question preach are you circumcised
for medical reasons yeah yeah what's
this daddy
daddy this is Fergie we're saying daddy
that you look good
we've fatty if it is the yard version of
that okay why don't you pick question Oh
see ya that's rolling fast hold up let
me go let me go on my seat yeah all
right so we're gonna go guys I'm gonna
take the next question will y'all go on
the brilliant idiots podcast that's what
shout out to my man Andrew Schultz we're
actually supposed to go on the podcast
twice [ __ ] Rona okay time [ __ ] just
didn't pan out in the second time Roman
I was supposed to go in on March 12
fourth I believe it's a Monday we were
going but on Friday [ __ ] was really
starting to blow up and I already
started canceling a lot of stuff so I'm
like I'm we're gonna flat in New York
and I'm glad we did it
because it turned out to be the
epicenter isn't it funny we live in the
epicenter of Canada which is much draw
Schultz is in the epicenter of the
United States Newark imagine if we would
have traveled people's yeah I'm not
taking no chances so we did not go on
the Schultz podcast but we'll be on
flagrant two at some point like oh the
things we so talk right yeah do you cool
dude yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah people
like y'all [ __ ] very comedians oh you
not like AIDS assaults meanwhile we was
like on the same so we invited him on
art so all right next question
yo Abba will you date an Indian girl no
okay you want to get in till we can get
into here's the thing right I grew up
around a lot of Bengali people people
from India Pakistan Sri Lanka yeah and
we would we would organize events and do
a lot of stuff and it was like pretty
much all ground group and I was a one
black dude there yeah and one thing I
realized and I learned when hanging out
with them is like for them family is
everything
their parents approval is everything to
like a scare
yeah they wouldn't even consider defying
their parents Yeah right so I'm like
when you gonna marry you her mama today
yay and they not all prove it's gonna be
an uphill battle the whole time so I'm
like I I don't want the struggle so I
would not date an Indian girl but I
think Indians are beautiful otherwise so
yeah that answer the question you you
went around it very well well it's not
it's not a matter of looks to help they
were very attractive no then I saw what
drama they had to go through to be in a
relationship like that like [ __ ] I'm
not sneaking up high no building so I
can kiss you like the [ __ ] you I'm not
dropping you off like ten corners not be
like me dating you should not be a
double-oh-seven mission ah that's right
I'm not some secret agent what the [ __ ]
is all this extra stuff I know so that's
why I wouldn't be an Indian person
so what's questioning that preach like
are you friends alright someone someone
now someone paid money so they get their
questions yeah baba shot brother in
Dayton air I was in Montreal last summer
and I went to Churchill club and I'm at
the baddest MILF and smashed yeah I
might move too much draw Churchill book
is pretty much the place a fine meal
especially on the Tuesday really
Churchill in Thursday 30 Thursday's
clothes but yeah listen if you want to
find women you go find them all over my
straw so you know what you're right she
does yeah okay so here's the next
question preach how old are you I'm 30
and I'm 29 so there's about eight you're
get yeah 36 okay no games
here we go from Ashanti Smith and a few
of your videos I can relate with
domestic violence the last seven months
out of our three year relationship he
put his hands on me okay
my question is how can I see heal my
supplements lubrano help boo-boo I am no
therapist professionally I do not
overstep my bounds
there's a fire in the in your house
don't call your boyfriend call the fire
department call a youtuber especially
not would not know fire youtubers are
better at starting fires
trust me so yeah I can't help you with
that unfortunately but you know God
speak to you I hope you recover really
well
what's your MBTI type from Shay pay two
dollars I'm like me you know at least
added a drop of five if you want a
question but I'm gonna take it - Shay
would you go on the h3 podcast it's a
YouTube podcast I mean sure it's not a
podcast that particularly like button
sight all right we got Luke here and
Luke 2 to 1 2 to 8 Thank You shout-out
to you for 279 that's a very specific
number hi Ivan preach how is the dance
scene in Montreal
[Laughter]
that's all we have two sinks
all right side two odds for 20 pounds or
is it 20 euros I don't know my
currencies 20 pounds thank you for your
thank you for speaking so much truth and
so much sense in the world where people
have their heads on backwards do you
like any UK hip hop
I like UK listen okay everything yo you
can't house I love how they just bring
babe to the [ __ ] like it's like you
don't wait when you hear Canadian
hip-hop it's okay but you hear they're
hard influences things and would be
trying to hit emulate but in the UK they
really flip t got the own thing
my favorite David so shout out to him I
think he put out one of the best R&B
albums of all time so shout out to these
can't you guys got great
yes 2-step garage and here's a throwback
Daniel Bedingfield yeah I gotta get do
this I gotta do this I gotta get through
this all right you know what what I like
was this cheese there's cheese you know
like that's how I learn hard to get my
English accent going on but wherever
yeah yeah
Kane helpers are the story lads love
from Dublin a shout outs John any mega
suggestions yo hit me up on Instagram
and then I'll send you my list above God
Atlas on Instagram Harry Roberts with
the pounds ever preach is there anything
which has pleasantly surprised you about
people in your community in the wake of
the Koba 19 pandemic yeah they don't
give a [ __ ]
now that a lot of people black people in
the community black people like it
events it depends a lot black people in
the states it's really like it's two
steps if you're either there really
cautious they don't get out they close
everything you don't see nobody or the
opposite when you really don't give a
[ __ ] reckless uh-huh so it's just me
what surprised me um I mean listen
honestly in Canada we're doing a really
good job so I'm very proud of people out
here and they're taking it really well
and the government's responded pretty
well so I'm happy with it
so I'm pleasantly surprised afroman says
ABBA what's your favorite anime my
favorite anime is a GTO a great teacher
onizuka that's a throwback a lot of
people don't know about I mean when I
highly recommend it very funny probably
the funniest enemy I've ever seen and
super inspiring and it was like really
good for me I need to get on this ship
yeah yeah alright can you read my name
without messing it up
that Pratchett that's nice but this
protect us may see ya gotcha test
projectors nice yeah it's possible I got
that [ __ ] yeah alright ten euros from
Khalid one day mr. faucitt some love
from friends that even though we don't
love you back whispers [ __ ]
he got a little French in here all right
we got J curry Williams damn I gotta
drop some change just to get a question
answer well it's because so many people
are dropping change they kind of jumped
the line you know it's kind of like
China shaking what are you on
polyamorous relationship I mean it's
cool that's cool it's just the best
thing is to communicate yeah that's
really what it is communication is the
key yeah a lot of things yeah um I have
no real opinion on it if you do it you
do it and you enjoy it great for you to
me it's just not for me but I don't mind
it for other people all right let's take
a question here
Abin preach are you guys here to take
down one bitter [ __ ] at a time no no I
don't care if someone's bitter I stay
away from them it's not my job no no no
no you know what you mean you post them
you pin their comments in the comment
section yes yeah you you are Chiyo Tomic
shout out to you ten ten dollars
hopefully it's u.s. dollars I have a
question how did you guys leave
pre-title we meet you yeah we saw the
story no no you tell them you tell them
I've been talking too much
you know I saw Nancy Nancy Hughes film
those Nancy vents at some point I called
him to put up a video of me dancing or
you know a real whatever and then he
called me to do one project and after
the project we started talking yeah and
it just so happens that we both started
in comedy the same time no we started
after but they may have been we started
talking I was like yo you're really good
with the camera and I was like I could I
got some things I want to talk about
to film I pay you to edit and you're
like well I'm gonna do the same thing so
instead of being competition how about
we just do this [ __ ] together and I'm
like oh okay cool
let's try it we tried a couple of times
the rest is history and after that a
couple of months into filming you were
sitting right there and he was like yo
um I start so yeah I started to do calm
you know I was like oh [ __ ] I started in
comedy you started in English I started
in French and that's where we try to
think about our first comedy show
yeah right to put up as our first time
the show which was at the Yellow Door
yeah
in McGill yeah amigo ghetto and then
after that we went and another one at
MacLaren's pub right and then we did
another video that really blew up in
much low and were we were planning to do
another song MacLaren's pub and that we
don't really blew up in the city running
in the province and then [ __ ]
will always tagging on your wishes
border or Sony I'm sure we have a soul
and I'm the one I'll collide yeah yo we
need to cancel that show because I don't
wanna I don't wanna
yeah turn people away on driver I
remember yeah let's do it the proper way
let's cancel that show set up another
one at the this story as long as [ __ ]
yeah but that's the way that's what it
is all right Adrian Barbosa Christian Oh
or Messi Christian for me only because I
think Messi is more talented by I think
Christian Oh from what I see I think
works harder and I just like his story
better but both Greek towns I don't
think either one preach how long did you
practice top waiter capoeira for six
years hmm my name was never for Zhang Li
do was me official which means the blood
that runs away because I was not Nestle
blocking kicks I was not in Italy you
know I was just going back to better
it's act right my sister did it for nine
years
her name is Aakash it which is a it's
not food it's a sort of pastry pastry my
girlfriend did it for two years
her name was college avail college she
failed was a fish but she had she used
to choose to like having long hair that
she would put like a long as braids
another hotel in the fish okay
cool sparkles 24 preach what's your
advice on saving my marriage is it
already example a [ __ ] will happen like
I don't know what happened saving your
marriage saving your marriage from what
crocodiles having in marriage from what
a guy lurking on your girls I mean if if
it's just if it's just normal [ __ ] you
just need to talk about it right right
but if it's your girlfriend comes back
from the office and you ask her how was
your day and she said well there's a new
guy at the office and you asked well how
is he and she said well he's mysterious
you're [ __ ] bro burned or burned a
whole relationship there's nothing you
can do about that when a girl fight
another man mysterious if your girl
finds another man mysterious you fail
all right except defeat shout-out to mr.
mango head thank you for the dollar
we got CC thrower okay she's been asking
this question this whole chat which she
now paid money to get answered and I was
paid how about 21 am I too young for you
yes
Ashanti Smith thank you I look look for
further help my family and friends tell
me I'm beautiful a good-looking but I
always end up crying because I think
that I'm ugly and we'll be single
forever
am I being ungrateful
oh I really can't tell the thing is
there's two things in that question okay
if you're finding your friends that
leaves you beautiful well it's not about
you okay it's about them thinking you're
beautiful which goes to the second point
you really have to work on your
self-esteem there's something wrong with
your self-esteem I've seen some bad
[ __ ] out there that was really
beautiful but they didn't think it
therefore there is really a question of
self esteem you have to work on that
yeah question what is your favorite
Jubilee clip you've recorded Congrats
often under K Thank You Christopher
swamp
um what's SC k what kind of dollars that
yeah you looked that up my favorite
Jubilee clip probably the yeah she was
probably my favorite one just because it
was great you had her and then you had
the guy at the end who had far more
modest wants and desires yeah it's V big
dollars Swedish yeah okay sorry that's
videos with this aren't they part of the
European Union why would they just have
euros no they're they're not worth okay
cool Umar Khan I think you should
revisit the China video no but I
appreciate the money bro here we are
let's see who's next don't play games
mm-hmm you guys are funny as hell when
will you get on TV cable do you have any
tips on single dads dating Andrew Walker
um
listen Angela this is it it's much
better to be a single dad than it is to
be a single mom diamonds
think that men with kids is really a hot
in queue and the fact that you're
responsible and you're taking care of
your [ __ ] they will love it so don't
stress it bro you're not in a bad place
I'm gonna give you that tip treat your
kids like they're dogs
you're gonna walk them in the park go to
the park with Jody [ __ ] it's crazy what
I'm about to say but if you want yo that
is some kids what happens right like
when a girl looks at an Instagram if she
sees a man with a kid in it look cute
together uh-oh
when I see a woman with a kid together
am i yeah I have
so this is me jackaroo williams shout
out to you just curious because I asked
quite a few times people this question
with different answers what do you think
our men's biggest problems with pleasing
women sexually and vice versa preach I
hate to let you go first
what is whip what do you think is men's
biggest problem with pleasing women
sexually and vice versa
big women [ __ ] is too complicated but
the reason for that is really because
they don't communicate people do not
talk in everything I feel like we're in
an age where when the days where
everything is awkward to people as like
people are not like our fraid of
confrontation but consultation to them
is not even fighting or arguing it's
just talking about comfort or discomfort
so yeah man think that sometimes women
your [ __ ] is really complicated and they
don't pay attention and stuff like that
but they also don't open up they don't
solve not opening up about your feelings
not only talking about I feel sad right
now it's just being able to say to
someone yo what do you want what do you
actually want what do you actually mean
so that's the thing it's like they think
it's complicated they think women are
complicated to satisfy because they
don't talk about it because they don't
go well he says big up on 300 in facts
gto is a top 5 anime my good man has
good taste we don't both have to answer
your answers good shaman oh five old
lion $5 shout out to I love that shot at
Drake well I wish more success for you I
love GTO but you should seek golden boy
GTO of it we didn't really have me on
that but shout out to you breakfast you
have a mango channel oh yeah yeah I need
to do more with it though I recently
found you guys's channel you guys are
honest with your content and your point
of view in great humor Congrats on
hitting 300k how do you guys first meet
we already covered up so you got to
scroll up sooo higher
we appreciate you same with Julien Lesar
thank you for your devotion do a video
on toxic parents
today not today not today all right I'm
just trying not to meet miss anything
there's so many [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I
can't keep up
all right guys all right guys you guys
got to slow down these donations this is
getting too hard can get some throw down
go ahead I can't keep up
oh my god they're coming in so fast
they're coming in too fast guys I'm
panicking
I'm literally okay Shawn Romero I just
want to say you guys are funny as hell
I'm glad supports you and we're glad you
support us thank you very much Brian
Finley
what are your community influences
principal I know that your floors is
Dave Chappelle and just the way that you
tackle things that are difficult to
tackle now you take a lot of risk right
I don't know what my influences are I
like sitcom stuff like that in the way
of acting it's crazy because it affects
it affects mine it affects my comedy now
also what am i influences oh jeez I like
Katt Williams yo Katt Williams is I
gotta admit that was one of my
influences you like him when he's
fighting kids know what he's buying you
never fought a kid he final teenager no
we got beat by he's fighting lost he
lost Katt Williams is a record is Owen
seven but the comedy of Katt Williams
yeah he's genius yo dad nobody's gonna
do the storytelling of Katt Williams I
love that [ __ ] oh my god I gotta admit
that's one of yeah yeah to me you want
to leave out there I respect that
here we go dem Studios you ever been to
upstate New York thoughts if you ever
been was upstate high it's north of New
York but keep see I don't know [ __ ] do
you tell me and it's a no for me I think
I have all right like Buffalo and all
right here we go
Melvin need hammer I'm 23 French and I
want to start doing video simulator you
in English what's your advice should I
get a camera just start doing it
lift your cellphone or whatever just get
decent audio I don't care if you record
with the second devices audio is more
important the visuals always so that's
my
nice to you gracious Massaquoi Congrats
off your turkey got some skin in the
game with this $5 okay maybe calm down
sniggers I've got some skin in the game
with 500 general advice for 20 year-old
Gauss and also a but where did you get
your hoodie we're actually gonna be
starting the hoodies online at our
merchandise store so if you look at any
video there's a little link in the
description you guys can get this hoodie
there everybody like from here would
follow us on instagram as well
yeah general advice for 20 year old gals
preach general value take your [ __ ]
sign and you're not as great as you
think you are hmm I'm not no advice for
you just don't starfish when you [ __ ]
are the atomic what's your business yeah
not even the person you're dating yeah I
find it kind of crazy when people share
that Jeremy doliveira definitely do a
video on the consequences of bad
character one day Ali shoutout to you
hey I'm gonna preach I'm eighty getting
ready to graduate from high school do
you guys have any advice for anyone
going into college in adult life
Congrats on 300k subs man's take your
time yes you know what just give advice
to young people preach take your time
and [ __ ] take your time to be alive
inform yourself be open about a lot of
things but but but yeah take it take
your time take your time this ain't no
race yeah it's a matter of song
yeah life will tell you that you need to
hurry things up let's have to have a
certain amount of success yeah your
classmates or high school friends you're
gonna see them doing great some of them
doing terrible some of them disappear
and some of them faking it you got your
journey you take your towel that you
don't matter you guys going on playing
it true Akash we're bringing you up yeah
we already covered this maybe sir it
really brought us up yeah they mention
this on the podcast plan at some other
point okay whoa would you two both
threesome together with a female no no
no this question would come in [ __ ]
Bosnia yeah Don Ricky
preach win I know you were Asian you
don't know what happiness that bro
when I knew you were Haitian you don't
know how much happiness that brought me
and I was hella proud to notice a more
thing
thanks for a Muslim man
all right thank you very much sparkles
24 says he wants a divorce cuz I have
trouble keeping my hands to myself and
not respecting his space I never hit him
though I'm trying to change any advice
stop doing that dumb [ __ ] you're doing
I'm no expert but stop doing stop doing
this [ __ ] that she wants to divorce
now that means it's really bad if he
wants a divorce
yeah he wants a divorce what do you mean
by keeping your hands to yourself you're
always on him you never hit him that's
me let me wet maybe she just like grabs
and don't don't don't do that don't [ __ ]
that hands you up in the divorce but I
guess it's too late now
okay it's too late apologize how do you
handle situation where your wife refuses
to go along or satisfy your specific
sexual desires or finishes and change it
for our beat it depends on what your
finish it is is it do you want to pee on
her being your honor to poop on her yeah
it depends what
I can't answer and it's not because it's
you satisfied if sure it's your it's not
because your desire finishes that she
has to do it yeah and why are you
married to a woman that you're not sure
wanted to engage in those positions to
begin with that's weird to me it's like
that would be something that you would
settle before you ever get married so if
you got married and you don't know she's
into your fetishes you got a problem
eyes if anything where that person is
from and where the background is you
know I mean yeah you miss one you have
to see what's up to that person that's
at five pounds right there hy thank you
very much moving on hmm unable to
connect yes yes
hopefully we're still going good you
guys still with us what's going on in
the chat I'm still working no no it's
your internet is garbage maybe that's
what it is or no somebody else goes wire
it's working right yeah but just me I
can't I can't access it from you my
Internet's fine no we're good
yeah oh why don't we just take some
other random question that we have if we
can't see the donations unfortunately
I'm a few mayor that's all good all
right big up from the UK about what
Clippers do use for the trims because
they look wavy I'll be honest with you
I'm like the last person you should ask
about hair clip precision like that I
don't know nothing about nothing nope
Abid I only have two ladies now I got
like at least six or seven I just don't
rock some of them it's a really great
them all welcome [ __ ] the guy I be used
to my abhi show yeah she let me to
recede metal tones for seeker happy
Easter my heavy shell yes happy sure to
use well my other four brothers GT or
more like get the [ __ ] out whoa that was
so trendy make someone a moderator I
don't screw enough to us know what that
[ __ ] means I mean that she gives without
fighting so why would you need a met
moderator yeah maybe it's just I get the
spam people I guess what a $2.00
gee Muhammad I'm in the word
how does [ __ ] taste like that's how you
know you grew up in a Muslim family
skies his booty he doesn't want to do
the Haram its well of course out of
wedlock you're not supposed to be fun
they're just like making hey guys I
really applaud it I can't see some of
these but I will try to make an effort
to see this all right love you guys
content it made me stop being angry at
myself and focus more on myself I'm glad
age 19 we appreciate you let's see here
Akeelah Jones preach do you think I
should slide in Abbas deems no that's
such a weird question no you shouldn't
you should either neither to respond or
not gonna respond listen I talk to him
sometimes and he doesn't even respond
and this business you know I mean so
yeah he's not don't don't do it
especially if you live far if you're not
from the mature area was the point I
live in Washington DC I wanna I don't
wanna I wanna hit I want to hit and find
an Abbas it's not gonna work
she's not gonna work was the point don't
ya I wouldn't do that
me myself and I shout out to you for an
OK which I'm pretty sure it's what I
don't know Haram is halal I don't know
no no no but I'm is pretty much the
opposite Abba why did you leave Islam
because I just didn't believe ABBA
can you stop being a philosopher and a
player at the same time who are you
what does that even mean to you do you
know what that mean I don't even know
what that means have no idea what that
many ambition I have trouble meeting
fellow Ethiopians women they like to get
chased by gnana [ __ ] you know who any
advice
do you know who Chris in Hawaii oh I'm
sorry I don't know what to tell you
because I don't know how to meet fellow
how to shut it so you don't actually
yeah this is not my strong suit so
you're asking the wrong person
thoughts on the rise of prostitution
because of courts yay prostitution I
guess live your life it's the service as
a woman I love your content I think it's
important in this new world where men
are often unfairly lumped together
internalized thank you very much little
universe yeah
all these okay this is so much in terms
of let's say let's pick something that
we want to talk about my girl broke up
with me because I kept talking about
five G conspiracies yeah you're annoying
his foot that's why she broke up with
you that's why she broke up with you
ignoring this book I think that's a
valid reason to break up with someone
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you talk too much
about anything like eat
for everything if you like manga like
this dude loves mangas he's a manga
aficionado if he was only talking to me
about mangas mm-hmm it'd be a problem
like [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up with your
dumb ass [ __ ] right you know what I
mean but the fact that he doesn't talk
about it and it's like I like alcohol
right I don't always talk about how cool
if he's not into that I'm not gonna talk
to him about it right if I have some I'm
gonna offer him a glass but I'm not
gonna be like yo yo take some of this
yeah that's the same thing to me this
equivalence when it doesn't want to
drink doesn't drink no bottom then with
the drinking mm-hmm someone that doesn't
really is mine you're 5g conspiracy [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up about your dumb [ __ ]
all right here we go
we got to resign do you guys have any
plans to come to Oregon and do a show
man he wanted we wanted list we was
getting their visas we were working on
it I'm not I'm not planning on traveling
anywhere this is done years over for
traveling dude it's done we we lost
quite a bit of money in festivals and
quite a bit so you know but I'm pretty
optimistic about the future like this
year I'm staying in and I'm making a lot
of YouTube videos listen I've seen some
people that have lost the amount of
money that we lost in shows lost it in
and what la boss oh yeah Congrats
no not knowing that both letters at New
York and I building New York buddy books
and money seems there oh yeah okay stock
yeah people that people that lost the
amount of money that we lost in shows
I've seen some people losing that in
stock options and maybe they were
devastated
yeah so we've lost a whole lot become
what is feel good and we cannot complain
I don't believe that we can complain but
the traveling is done for the year
yeah Rambow ray thank you for the $5
billion preciate so I always notice that
once trick streamers do it they do it
no sub really appreciate things they do
it like that roll through them and I
understand them yeah don't know of you
answered already but does the blow-up
doll have a name
loyal was based on the war on the poor
star yeah so apparently the names Lloyd
it's written on the back yeah it
supports Lord Arryn Jackson sounds like
Derek Jackson congratulations gentlemen
I appreciate you guys and appreciate
your approach to issues in the content
you produce keep it up definitely an
asset to our people oh [ __ ] all right
Thank You Man oh all right
this is going crazy sooo higher and Z's
white girl tried as a black man preach
was hilarious thank you because that was
funny like because he knew the thing
gonna happen is that he go fish is some
gold [ __ ] like I gotta admit like Abba
is movie King and the fish it's some
cold [ __ ] like videos and he doesn't
tell me about the videos okay so when he
presents a video to me like yo I got
some good the only thing he says it I
got some good [ __ ] for you and then he's
the key presses blame like okay today I
saw something breach so so I see that
for the first time I never seen it kill
me it got me I got it got me alright
here we go
Becca Panda what y'all think about
Jamaicans my grandma always mean to me
she point a knife at me boy what did you
do you know you might say let me let me
tell you a little something all right
me love to make a meal of Jamaican
culture here we have the Jamaican people
especially a grandma she pull a knife on
you what did you do yeah was it her or
was it biology it's a great question
would you guys ever go to Philly no
actually yes I was supposed to go there
was this girl that I knew who lived here
for some times and she moved to Philly
and then we was lowkey dating not really
though but she was like come to Philly
this and that and I was like yeah yeah
yeah but it's the problem with her is
like she's from the deep south and she
from like a real
Christian family like you gonna burn in
hell if you don't believe you so I'm
like oh you know I'm never gonna believe
in Christianity why we still seeing each
other and she said well I'm hoping
that's gonna change over time saying but
that's not so what happens then she's
like well you're gonna burn in hell for
all eternity like you're not saved and I
was like this is such a weird way to
think some people think like that yeah a
lot yeah so I couldn't say anything her
you're not saved I was like whatever
[ __ ] was flinging and I got one of my
cousin one of my favorite cousins mmm
like like this guy is so cool all right
so but his sister he was born Adventists
ah okay so he was using that but he got
out of that yokte out so my sister is
deep in that crazy talking about yeah I
don't approve of mixed marriages and
stuff like that that's someone he was
having a baby shower for cuz one of his
friends couldn't have a baby so he was
the donor right I heard her clearly say
because she was there and she was just
like
like a bunch of bikers and stuff like
that and he was talking about the girls
the girls that were there it's just like
well okay any one of you want something
to drink and Isabelle's like the what
Jezebel was I mean because in the Bible
Jezebel is a [ __ ]
man you're religious but she has a room
I mean it was so sweet that you almost
won in Lenox yeah cuz it's like know why
she did it
here we go we are on maverick hello what
is your advice for shine [ __ ] who
can't seem to acquire the sweet embrace
of a consenting female poom poom
shout out to you for consenting alright
twenty twenty consents important because
they don't really interact with people
that much my advice to you bro is you
got to take risks if you want to succeed
so if you're shy you have to overcome
your shyness if you want the goods that
come with being bold not saying you got
to become fully bold but you do have to
sometimes come out of your shell at the
end of the day I do not recommend you
being in your comfort zone if you want
different results you got to do
something different
alright so we have a big 100 fat damn
what's a zillion dollar yeah Australian
dollars like Canadian dollars yeah shout
out to you $100 from mama's boy
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna do miss miss breech and
respect to you cuz you said mrs.
preached thank you yeah yeah
Eric McIntyre who would win in a fight a
born preach and Abba would you pull
Bridges hair be honest love your content
keep up the solid work question pull his
hair who would win the fret I probably
give it to preach and to Abe Freeman
I've been checking our reaction videos
those bumble reaction classic bumble oh
he's talking about know his Pinder it
was not bumble was back in the days of
first think he just may have mixed us up
with other [ __ ] oh yeah
Sally $10 Canadian side off misses
retracted thank you very much
Ashanti Smith would you read my first
question I shouldn't have read it in
that voice you're good abla it was funny
as [ __ ] love you both and I wish suggest
for both of you thank you thank you and
I hope you find some healing good ODB
travels do you think it's okay for your
girlfriend to remain friends with her ex
and I allow them to continue to let that
ex have access to contact her ooh
preach should your girl be allowed to be
in contact with her ex to me
yes because I'm really not the jealous
type like not at all okay and yes I
don't in whatever if there's something
that has to happen it will happen
mm-hmm you know what I mean yeah so I
don't have control over that so I let it
go my girl could contact her ex that
would not something that would bother
hmm it's not something that did as a
matter of fact
hy shoutout to you what's your advice on
vetting women you let into your life um
listen I tell this to everybody I don't
watch what women say i watch what they
don't say and i watch how they act what
they don't say is also really important
you know one thing that women always get
mad at me for is like a boy you don't
see me carry I feel like you don't ask
me questions about me or like like where
I'm from and this is tough on my baby I
don't need to ask I don't say baby
that's weird I say I tell them I yo I
don't know I said baby I thought you
were like what did I ever say it's funny
because I would say man you always give
me [ __ ] the same Donald's a big one of
them a weird moment a woman but I tell
the girls I'm like yo I'm not gonna
learn about you by asking you questions
that you are very like Univerity for you
know cuz you're gonna present a facade
so I'm gonna ask you strange questions
I'm like what's the worst thing you've
ever done on dates and then that way you
see when they're not prepared people
have a lot of your ass I'm just like I
always come up with really good
questions that people aren't expecting
that are interesting you know what I'm
saying yeah because either you share
something that you did terrible you even
be honest with me but then I might judge
you on what that terrible thing was
depending on what it was or you're gonna
have done nothing terrible and I'm like
okay that's a you know I mean it's like
that but it'll be video yeah you know
try to find a black girl black yeah if
not in your response no it's in what you
don't respond or how you lie or you
maneuver this [ __ ] right that's yeah
Harel hey hey leader hi I'm from
Dominican brother to ZOA
Torres old brother huh that's for you
what do you guys think of brothers
traveling outside of North America to
date women
I mean sure do you men if you have to
meet you traveled in travel but you have
to be conscious to put the customs of
the integral of the pub the people are
and that's it but I don't care I would
never go to a third world country to
find a wife that's be personal that's
different because that's where yeah yeah
I love you guys hilarious thank you
Shonda tawny Overlord chaos who has the
bigger Johnson
don't like I said gay ask questions how
would we know thinking out here
comparing what the [ __ ] is y'all doing
what is this currency right here Lucifer
Martel this currency doesn't even seem
real this is like a lightning bolt [ __ ]
what is it Indian rupee hey uh do you
guys did a video on dr. Shiva ayyadurai
PhD MIT love you both a Baba a bit more
[ __ ] the Indian girl appreciates you
hopefully I didn't see the beginning of
this hopefully you didn't see the
beginning of this life cast where I said
I wouldn't didn't mean you girl and why
but go watch it I got love for my Indian
people so don't worry it's not bad do
you write do you watch the one on ones
that the producers the bruisers won't
want to Instagram we mean you know they
have battles on Saturdays about
producers the one against boy and it was
like no a premiere no that's almost any
Riley vs. babyface and I was just that
was just miss Pooh bunny
a pigeon [ __ ] a pigeon can you please
flip that in your virtual town hey
appreciate you miss pull bunnies and I'm
sorry if I yo
Geronimo Mooney my condolences to those
that duck lost their lives in the Nova
Scotia shooting yeah there's a dude that
have you seen problems like an active
shooter yeah
Marko's image you would be smashing in
if you came to Siberia funny you said
that there's actually a big-ass youtuber
from Bosnia who started following us
recently oh yeah and I creeped up in our
Instagram there's go I'm not going I am
yeah I love serve you need my services
oh and I was chillin with some service
when I was in when I was in Moscow not
must go in there st. Petersburg Russia
and I yo you you yeah yeah we're certain
being what
so we got a little it was nope they're
funny funny ass [ __ ] that's why
I would go to surgery
yeah good because the party yeah yeah
Slayer piano man what are you guys
advise for approaching ladies in real
life and getting a date played keys at a
comedy show to meet people and maybe
some ways but the vibe was always very
one improve mom preach I'm gettin advice
yeah read the book the card read the
book read a book called entering the
senior society of a pickup artist that's
the beginning of it gonna tell you a lot
of things you have to improve you
suffers right and after that you can go
out there yeah all right let's see here
let's scroll back up mm-hmm
hey are you guys going to release your
documentary
Eric online that was Sally we have to
think about this we don't know what's
gonna happen like there's a lot of times
we have to rethink them even the
documentary yeah so you have to give us
time and finally yeah we're going to
festivals crystal McLean $2 appreciate
you shadow to you Varun Beshara thank
you for the 40 rupees really appreciate
that
Lucifer Martel one hundred rupees one
again I was the one who asked you that
question you dodo okay I appreciate why
we called you stupid
yeah here we go
shade $20 from Ethiopia Congrats on
three okay thank you my field bein
brothers appreciate you guys glad you
guys aren't doing the content so Abba
does your family speak or ammo or mark
my family speaks both my dad said their
or almost so they speak that and most
people who live in I just speak up mark
so my dad learns from this no you live
in that this difference will you live in
the mountains yeah it's mostly all
mountains chichi Marie where do you see
yourselves in five years ten years I
don't know I'm trying to focus on the
now and then we'll see later yeah yeah
Christian no ie how you gonna act like
the opium or bad yo we feel been dudes
have it bad they indoctrinate our women
hate us
Ethiopian free the opiate breath listen
I don't know what you've been through
mining is but like deal with your hurt I
don't think women are bad I don't think
you feel good women are bad I don't know
about the indoctrination I got there but
deal with your hurt me okay god bless
you
that's why I don't like reading comments
sometimes [ __ ] getting tense lately
they put their problems on Jonathan
Brown yo you guys are hilarious is so
real appreciate the content thank you
brother
Ave y'all the alien from Planet Mexico
all right appreciate the donation
alright let's take another egg Euler
question here
do you watch Demon Slayer yes I finished
the manga I'm up to date
I'm updated on everything brother have
you say that enemy I've watched it and
I've read the entire experience just
don't hear it don't wasto a nobody time
box
did you what yes of course it is always
yes yeah yeah
even I know yeah thanks you're a by
remember you're speaking some Crale a
couple of videos go you get any better
than Kapali man mmm
i found beautiful pool I mean uh value
no pity did it we hope I'm going to do
that like sometimes you date a girl you
lose interest you don't know why you
lose interest it was interesting what do
you guys think will happen after the
quarantine will everything remain the
same or will some things change this
question came from
dwell so wow so long hazel I watch you
because he what you think will happy and
after the quarantine will everything
remains the same or will some things
change because it I have so many
questions please it pre she is wrong
everything we [ __ ] up yeah everything
is not yeah the things are gonna change
yeah now I go back to normal yeah yeah
sparkles 24 no Abbas would you marry a
Muslim woman no yeah no no and if I had
to say why it's just because I don't you
have to listen if you say you're Muslim
I'm assuming your practice
and you really involved community like
you're about that life if that's the
case I don't want to because I will not
believe and I don't want to cause a
conflict for my children
ideally I would like for me and my
partner to share the same cultural
heritage or the view of how to raise a
kid so no when he started dating his
wife anything you'd like to say which
means we better better ugly
at least we're there yeah hey Noah says
what's your full name government name
who you the fan huh what's your real
name a book could actually pass as a
Serbian no anyways moving on
boring Frost hunter that's what I call a
ginseng me but my sovereign SEC would
ban food that goes in mulch um Bob this
was just such a [ __ ] like
stereotypical like i'ma just play these
[ __ ] really ask my question why don't
you tell him what he said you fed a
listen I'm from a part of Quebec and I
have my mind my sister doesn't want to
[ __ ] with me no war so what should I do
and I'm like [ __ ] you cousin what's more
I don't believe people should get
married because it makes people lazy in
their relationship also it leaves out
the divorce courts what's your take mmm
do you I mean listen people don't need
to get married to get lazy in the
relationship don't get it twisted well I
put it our marriage
is the person yeah but do you don't do
you dad alright power man I'm seeing a
woman from Bosnia right now it probably
won't go far because our bedroom
activities leave me to believe I'm just
a finished ER I'm black sounds good
[ __ ] you might be this [ __ ]
going into two dollars that I got a
question for y'all [ __ ] I don't think
you know how this works
[ __ ] are you gonna be like two dollars
extra and you can ask a question a
question and give $4 reach any tips to
help learn Portuguese speed you have to
practice yeah unless you have to
practice and since I'm moving some of it
because I'm not practicing yeah pick up
um down I but when you're gonna grow
your hair back business yeah and will
happening when they like full kill
killing have you guys mitigated
conflicts between the two of you in your
line of work how have you guys mitigated
concept between the two Union talk about
it hmm like live the [ __ ] that I
disagree the most about III rebels I I
disagree with this guy to most like
that's the guy that I disagreed of most
but because we're able to talk about we
don't air our [ __ ] out right because
we're able to talk about it that's how
we be able to listen if if we weren't
petty with each other if there was no
communication if there's no way this
woulda lassitude the amount of time that
lasted hmm so we talk I like the answer
hey preach how did you like Russia loved
it I want to go back st. Petersburg oh
my god the people like a girl that is a
eight year is a three over there the the
architecture is great it was good it was
good I had fun I really had fun
I was really
because I'm blacking Russia and the the
people that brought me there which was a
dance competition they avoided me too
they really said like yet don't do not
take the metro hmm cuz then you there's
no place to run or hide but other than
that okay shot you Smiths I'm 20 by the
way I have a chance to date you Baba but
whenever the quarantine is over
listen okay you wait that's weird you
experiencing what Elliot Jones are you
guys gonna do a video on Steph Freeman
moving on but thank you for the donation
look at it I'm all stood in Montreal hey
guys you guys are quickly becoming my
favorite channel other than amazing
honey gold Jasmine okay how do y'all
feel about someone drafting an actual
dating contract
well someone invited me to dating group
on Facebook and they had a Google Doc in
there a dating contract I mean I'm not
against it it puts everything clear yeah
but they did contract really what it is
is really what the dating contract is
really what what you should talk about
this it's not called a dating contract
it's just you talking about what you
should or should not do when you're
dating hmm are we exclusive oh that's
what a contract is right right and and
and you infringing on that contract was
what Rangers trouble right so so people
have dating contract it's not as
elaborated as a dating contract it's not
good in the sense of a dating contract
right well yes you should have that
mm-hmm
yeah call that no and I would also say
you already have made in contracts
they're called prenups
they're called marriage agreements so
they're not dating I mean it's not
you did when you do a prenup you did the
dating you know I mean did you yeah
got any advice on spitting game in
general yeah go watch our video that we
did on is dating the game and all my
advice I was like five videos ago yeah
oh right let's see what we got here
answering a lot of questions here
have you ever guys done a video on black
fishing uh naked mole-rat we appreciate
your donation I don't know what naked
black fish in it it's like fishing sir
no I know that is hi guys you still want
want that assignment on the issues with
video games it will be ready for
tomorrow mate what who's done huh Jojo
nota
hi guys you still want that assignment
on the issues with video games did we
give somebody in the same unit hi guys
you still want that assignment on the
issues [ __ ] we handing out homework it
will be ready but isn't it strongly okay
my girl just because she's watching this
[ __ ] just ex me she's like we were 16
not 15 okay we were 16 when we started
this
okay avol a vampire hunter d our blood
the last vampire our birdie the mighty
vampire hunter diva rings a bell blood
over the last rapper I'm not a vampire
I don't like vampire enemies so no sassy
semen could preach what are you drinking
I'm drinking Glenmorangie in rem
Glenmorangie Highlands cotton single
malt aged ten years yeah Scotch
Sustaita Tyrell per putz his rustle
shoutout to you for the $2 donation
david Delaney big fan love to see you
guys in Albury after the Rona are you
guys planning on doing the anime channel
also live stream I remember you
mentioning you haven't seen Jojo has
that changed yeah I've watched all the
Jojo episodes I've read the manga as
well great anime this one thing how Bini
is not a real city okay it's a bus stop
on the way of New York City what a bit
zoom out there but I'm this thing is
yeah yeah
sparkles 24 no problem we appreciate it
one question is anyone claimed the 1000
peach run yet no no nobody has it's
gonna be crazy if they do we just put
that there as a goof but if someone does
congratulations to them congrats on
through and okay what's your advice on
Patrice oh and the others relationship
advice if you're familiar with him yeah
he's good money yeah the chief the chief
is the man yeah he's pretty good yeah
I'm a big fan I love a lot of thing that
he says there's a lot of dislike that he
says that I was like just not supportive
and I started thinking about Mike he's
funny but he's right
you know I mean like he's really good
yeah big fan of mr. comedy special you
haven't seen an elephant in the room
it's one of my favorite comics yeah I'm
going over watch it here alright copy
Rudy for two dollars and you got a deal
anyways ninjas thanks for the $2 David
de l'année not preach you right we do
call it dirty albums here okay
man a lot of these [ __ ] asking
me they're nerding out on this enemy
stuff yo do you need hey yo I've been
watching you guys for a while if you
watch samurai champloo samurai Champloo
is the best soundtrack for any enemy the
old times son right I'm not being on
enemy yeah I know found myself yeah as a
dope-ass don't got old school yeah
really great artwork is really beautiful
and me y'all ready from Amber Heard to
get her butthole turned inside out
that's gonna hack was really weird
aw she's not gonna move in prison that's
not happening she's gonna get munched on
but not should not go to prison so might
she not want a prison they don't give
her probation you know these famous
bitching
can you guys talk about your cultures
the similarities and differences
Ethiopia from addis ethiopian fermentis
talk about our culture's are similar in
differences one fact there's too many
similarities between our culture's life
the food is not a thing he goes
different reasons everyone loves food
the differences they're loud were more
on the quiet antenna that's true we're
very conservative in that sense so moms
are the thing though no our moms are
conservative her mom's conservative my
know in terms of tempo loudness they
don't take up space my mom was very
quiet moms like Ethiopians are just
quiet people
yeah they are they don't take up a lot
of space like if you see them as
tourists you're not going to hear no no
no they're really quiet so now no
definitely read the fine print you don't
do it it's really meant for somebody
with a lot of money who's got money to
spend so I'm recommend you do that
that was a noise look a thousand dollars
on patreon so because you got a $1,200
yeah like just save your money bro
yeah we're good feel a peak Lu I found
your channel you know they love your
videos genuine thank you appreciate it
gracious Massaquoi double question and
value us humour and opinion preach have
how how have preached and his wife
lasted so long especially after dating
so young look I'm gonna sing wise look
because we didn't roll so much apart and
you don't know how a party girl from
your partner right so there's a bit of
luck there where where you're gonna grow
totally separately people really young
you could grow very part also mmm yeah
we grew the same and also she's
easygoing so we we sell with with
something that was that was compatible
very compatible so she's super easygoing
even though we're two separate people
like you meet my girl and you don't know
she's my girl you're gonna be like
that's impossible but it fits the fact
that we're not it's not so much what we
like that keeps us together it's what we
dislike when we go to a party and
there's people that are annoying or
there's a girl that we see there and she
has a new boyfriend and we like she
tests me on my foot something like that
that means some egregious [ __ ] you know
there's some compatibilities there so
there's a lot of luck there's hard work
there's a lot of hard work as well you
know your relationship stops when one of
the parties doesn't want to put any more
effort because they think it's not worth
it
so there's that so yeah Jerry no
shout-out to for the donation AVL the
alien from Planet Mexico in UFC 249
who do you have Mazda dollar who's smart
I didn't know is that confirmed
I don't know if it's confirmed if it's
confirmed I got new smart min-soo a bunt
a love the channel guys how do you feel
about twitch I feel like you would make
good content I mean I'm just focused on
YouTube because that's already enough
for me people sub when they come after
me start the whole [ __ ] and also I feel
like - it should be just for video games
if you don't do video games I don't know
it just feels weird to be on that
Constance we like you we we put so much
effort on this yeah I don't think we
could do that right now I think we I
think we missed the twist oh no it's
still there yeah yeah we get some make
money it's everyone's making money on
coach huge how do you guys make sure the
girl you're with knows you're serious
about not getting married and she can't
change her mind
you tell her that's my best if you
doesn't believe it I saw her no she
doesn't
if you think she can change your mind
you just keep smacking it down every
time she brings it up you don't even
give her any hope Abba dance for us
[ __ ] do I look like a monkey [ __ ] out
of here
Alex scores a $20 we appreciate the
donation bro holy [ __ ] alright hey I
love your channel came across the
Jubilee video called who's the locust
y'all so check it out we did check it
out just our video didn't come out great
so it never came out Joelle Cooke love
your content watch your channel in two
days that's a lot of videos might do god
bless your soul fan make us so my ivory
preach can you turn your life into my
phone's notification so you can you can
united singers keep up the good work in
state as always honest and truth to
yourself
[ __ ] throwback cool fine thanks for
calling out the stupid ease of the
silence e society love your videos thank
you appreciate it
alright preach have you listened to the
red pill movement what are your thoughts
on them yeah
documentary it's real yeah it's real and
the thing is that when I met ABBA
what am I Abba I was I was calling
myself a feminist and he smack that [ __ ]
down and I thought about it it was
before the red pill movement I thought
about my and I started looking about it
look into it and looking about the
discrepancies about all that movement
and yeah if you look at the word the red
pill documentary one of the first people
you meet on that documentary it says yo
I used to be a feminist and I used to
say that I was a feminist but their
national chance will switch because of
different reasons and yeah I saw myself
in that mmm so I believe it kind of sin
McDow thing I get it I really don't know
much about the red pill
I've even seen a documentary I started
documentary and the whole time I was
like oh right I was the brightest you
haven't seen it though yeah
here's the question who's the ash least
of the to love the contact would be him
for sure Ashley yeah but we mean you for
sure you wouldn't be a shiest like
Ashley yeah she's skin I have smooth
skin my skin is like baby smooth like
moisturize all the time so preach would
be the ashes I make today for a bath
with you you want to pull out elbows oh
yeah
do you boys elbows I've must raise
everything yeah you have to moisturize
right yeah but the one thing that would
make me yeah why did you know if you
don't moisturize your hands get asked
you know it's you moisturize a lot but
if you watch or you I really don't get a
[ __ ] you don't get out yeah I don't get
actually because my skin's I don't know
what it is just its baby smooth and I
take a lot more showers and he does and
the water here is chlorinated for sure
it's possible yeah
everyone want a but I'm gonna stay
behind this phone she's waiting for you
call ABBA have you been attracted to
white women do you feel guilty about it
[Music]
yes do I feel guilty about it no we mean
they're women naturally I'm going to be
attracted No why would I feel guilty
about all right here we go
two questions how did you guys manage
your time before getting to this level
of success and what motivated you to
keep going before the money started
coming in from Keenan hunt go ahead
mm-hmm I just put all my time into this
I saved up some money so I had time to
take to put my efforts into being a
better comedian and being a better
content creator I've time to just try
stuff and make a lot of content so yeah
all my time went to this [ __ ] which is
pretty much comedy in this you here we
are
JC the black guy wrote to six figures
what's it like to be successful youtuber
in Montreal second question preach has
to be a Haitian descent but how about
you AB I'm Ethiopian and what's it like
to be a successful youtuber Wow immature
I mean how it's just where to be
successful to be like for me it's weird
good
it's weird just just people recognizing
you and stuff like that but before I was
able just to tell my live when we were
walking down the street I was able to
tell my girlfriend where I knew these
people from
and now there's people that act like be
no mean he approached me and I'm like I
really don't
some crazy reactions hmm and that's
weird crazy reactions are weird people
are freaking out that is weird so how
you freaked out that much and not
knowing from them you're here much no
[ __ ] I live here yeah you're that much
of a for much don't know I'm from Utah
yeah hey guys I've been watching your
channel for more than two years now not
love and really respect you guys
watching you both inspired me to write
comedy skits is it cool if I can get
your opinion on them yeah they're great
do comedies can make make it interesting
make a lot of them get better some of
them are gonna suck most of them are
gonna suck in most but you'll get better
at so keep doing it hey a boy you said
you run an air B&B in one of your last
videos how are you faring in the current
market uh because you yeah there is no
air B&B right now it's the home market I
have a lot of revenue streams so it was
just one of many but for me now that
it's okay but for other people that
that's how they made money
tourism is dead so they're hurting like
everybody else preach I was wondering if
you spoke Asian is that more if so would
you have you introduced that into the
channel you must be new yeah if you look
further back enough especially if you go
on our Facebook page you'll see a lot of
those videos about Haitian language and
I don't methyl pees and all that stuff
you lab but you need to take these
donations and go buy some new garments
you got money is worth on that hoodie
okay I appreciate it Yousef sandy Simone
cook have you missed your podcast
episodes have you not done any recently
yeah we put one on our podcast is on
Spotify we've released one on Friday so
yeah so they should be going up every
week any advice for up-and-coming
comedians keep going open mics keep
writing keep getting better over
Podcast after one IVA and three spots
yes the a burn priest shall is one thing
that happened Prince podcast is another
Channel
yes sir let's see let's take some more
questions promise you guys we would do
this and we've been going for quite some
time [ __ ] a much left from
Chicago was left to you Christopher
Siobhan's back hey thoughts on Kent
Satanists and major religion see eye to
eye from Jubilee and finishing Cowboy
Bebop I haven't seen the Jubilee video
yet but maybe we'll watch it and seen
Cowboy Bebop yeah I have seen like come
on now
yeah I'm not a big fan I think it's well
done but it's not my yeah I bow could
you you could make serious money being
one of the few black anime youtubers
thank you both yeah I agree
it's just I'm really focused on this
main YouTube channel I don't want to
divide too much of my time just yet but
eventually once this is running we're
uploading every day it's gonna be hard
for me to run a second channel so I want
to at some point it's just not yet time
you guys do shows in the USA not yet we
can't travel were from Canada so we
can't travel yet no we're on lockdown
understand so Nikki Bronson loves you
guys have been watching you since I'm 19
I'm 21 now that's great
please consider reacting to the vid from
the cut called eliminate your date with
one press of a button
oh c'mon seen that yes so let's take a
different question let's take a
different question
Oh Joshua Crawford Congrats on the
milestone I just hit 75 cannons because
of youtubers like you guys that keep me
grinding congrats Joshua 75k is a great
one and this stuff is exponential if you
stay consistent and you make good
content the roof the sky is the limit
alright so keep being ambitious keep
trying [ __ ] pretty much
alright once a question er did anyone
inspire y'all become comedians and did
you guys have any super embarrassing
moments on stage also or listening to
ask three questions that want to calm
down
pick one did you have any super
embarrassing moments on the stage no not
super embarrassing so I had this bit
about how I hate taking the bus because
I'm somebody who's in a hurry but you
can't control the speed of a buck and
then sometimes when the bus is going and
a [ __ ] in a wheelchair wants to get on
you just like keep driving and leave the
guy in a wheelchair behind right it's
because I'm like yo it doesn't matter
you got wheels he's got wheels it's
roroa and everyone he laughs right
thing is as everyone was laughing this
girl in the wheelchair kind of just
popped out of the light like this I
don't return a little bit and I made eye
contact with her and she was there with
her mom and they were both staring at me
real hard and I couldn't like not
acknowledge that she was I was like hey
everybody look who rolled in and it got
really awkward cuz everyone saw the
wheelchair and I said rolled in really
stupid I was like I said did you guys
like that joke and if we're kind of
quiet so I realized he didn't like that
joke I was just like hey listen I can't
lie I feel bad but not really and I just
kept on with the show here's the thing
that was a competition show so people
vote at the end for who is lost and they
didn't and I won I won for sure wine
still still s of course it was a good
joke in this city you one of the tops
yeah when I saw it felt like that in
comedy like it miss y'all you gotta
admit like in English you're one of the
top yeah take another questions
I can't imagine you guys not being
together I don't think
I mean that's not true preach there's a
lot of stuff on his own he runs another
podcast for somebody else he does a lot
of individual success yeah unfazed we're
not together so yeah we make it work
separately quite a lot he can't imagine
it that's one thing but the reality is
we're not always like saying you can't
imagine P and Q key and Peele separate
but look at them now yo you know I mean
they're way bigger now than when they
were together so it doesn't necessarily
mean that they it's not because you
start off as a duo take Dave Chappelle
him and Neal Brennan you never know I
don't think we don't know we'll see
exactly oh we're gonna be pretty soon
exactly let's see yeah yeah you got a
good relationship bonus good thoughts on
Jordan Peterson um hopefully he recovers
ASAP from whatever he's going through
apparently he's been going through some
kind withdrawals from prescription drugs
so he was doing but so he got speed too
but I like one of his ideas so I'm with
it teach preach on markaba I'm learning
on my own I don't mean business there
you go there you go MFA the video of you
giving your mom paying off her house
payment has inspired me more than ever I
work hard every day so one day I can
bring much happiness or relief to my
folks much respect I appreciate the good
comment and my mom appreciates it too
my mom is not allowed to watch us breath
when I found out she was subscribed you
actually off three good be so hard man
and you know had you was her because it
was her full name and I'm like that's
what my mom would get my mom would
create a [ __ ] YouTube channel with
her government name I'm like lady if you
don't answer I called her right away
I said you unsubscribe now
that's why I made a fake account and I
gave it to her my mom doesn't get to
watch my mom doesn't get to watch her
YouTube channel
my mom's not watching this my mom's
watching I know my mom was that's funny
mom's been watching yeah report to her
so what dance styles do you guys enjoy
the most and when did you start dancing
and why there's not a desktop that I
enjoy the most like I do different
dances for different reasons so I enjoy
each one of them for different reasons
give them some examples man like house
it's a different [ __ ] journey when I
went on your house dance you know
whacking is for some other [ __ ] there's
some different things that I you know
accomplish what I'm wacky I gotta admit
I gotta admit the salsa gets me to
wonder you know we're not good she is
we've already had and when you see a
live band like they look at me and they
think I'm American so I go there and
maybe have the salsa band playing and I
go off good like I lose my shake right
this is good [ __ ] music you know I
mean mhm
like when we play that [ __ ] I go oh okay
okay
you're one of us I'm like no I'm not one
of y'all but I like that's my sheep
right like this salsa mmm
when it hits you the dance saw when I
danced all this for some other reasons
but when it hits me when they're like is
just clearest better hits me cut she's
on like a big jumbo jet it's crazy but
it's just but it hits you so there's not
a favorite one it's just to me it's just
like alcohol my different types for for
different reasons I mean yeah I I grew
it I think you pretty much covered it if
you want to see preacher and me dad's
just go to Instagram
sure there's like a post somewhere there
you know so there years ago I'm not
gonna be dancing on the stream for you
but no yes you guys want to see us
dancing you know where to look
destiny says congratulations a bond
preached on three okay we appreciate
destiny thank you for tuning in all
right yeah I know you're probably a
larger YouTube channel because you had a
check mark so respect we still haven't
gotten our check mark money oh but work
from YouTube to be like these guys are
official they haven't taken our planet
right yeah I sent an application just
with everything happening I'm not mad
you should have an only fans account
what army
yes that's for the lady I get the point
fruit-like need to have my girls [ __ ]
track you down and beat your ass that's
one thing that I'll go yeah
any advice for dating during this
pandemic don't next question
it's crazy it's hard time probably you
imagine trying to date during a pandemic
you'll only ask me there's some people
that that's hard to date here and they
got a $3,000 ticket each because their
passion betrayed them and the police
look at things like you got well what's
your address with your address all right
well you're supposed to be you're not
supposed to be together
Oh $3,000 tickets y'all ever heard of
Gabbar music and dancing
absolutely well you might like it no
have you heard of it no neither bye
Gabbar music sounds really weird sounds
like something I would enjoy yeah Gabbar
Gabbar a band preached favorite salsa
song for me it's by like a beta for me
of Barranquilla me Widow
there's some great sauce music that
comes out Africa too yes yes people
don't know this but there's a lot of
great salsa music that comes out of
African countries and it's some of my
favorite [ __ ] when I hear that ding ding
ding ding again King whoa
[Music]
I'll be out here sweating bricks looking
at home like yo what's up you trying to
get this salsa yeah you give her that
she leaves smiling is because we move in
so much you my sake listen my camera
can't handle the Fuego okay my camera's
out of focus because it's blushing
we're getting Russian okay listen we're
gonna yell too hot yeah well there's
nothing better than when you wrap up a
dance with a girl right and she looking
at you some type of way right she be
looking at you sometimes mm-hmm
and right afterwards you realized peace
I gotta grab the next bar and then your
days with the next Bronte she looking at
you like all nice and [ __ ] yeah so yeah
tell him tell him some stories about you
dancing and then I'll try to fix this
[ __ ] while you do that stories about me
dancing
and it's just it's really I got I got a
salsa bands partner why don't you move
my best friend right and who is it dirty
no it's fine keep going so we go day we
used to go dancing a lot and [ __ ] okay
and what I've noticed is just really the
it's crazy how people like that
different type of you spit right my this
is very old school cuz I go to a bath
like nobody dance with her like what her
bathroom I come back she dancing yeah
without on mono and give us you that's
not my broad but when you beside her
nobody gets yeah I don't mind that she's
not my broad even if she was my girl I
wouldn't be like yeah hmm preaches a
ballet dancer I did ballet yes yeah did
you guys make this channel mainly to
hate on women yes yeah the thing I don't
get is that we're either own sexual men
say that he throw sexual heat oral sex
from eternal not a [ __ ] we got another
heat not not not heterosexual heater
heater oh we're at all sexual men and we
did with women so therefore we're gonna
talk about our business listen again if
you eaten women out here and that's why
you eat or sexual that's cool be but me
I don't eat no poopoo man I know poom
poom my my night not home home but - hot
[ __ ] no no no way someone asked why do
you have that opinion of women from
third world countries okay so here's my
thing right
generally speaking third world countries
are often extremely religious which
means that there's a lot of shaming
there's a lot of sexual repression I
don't have anything against the people's
characters my thing is this right I like
people who in
the bedroom are not just submissive and
do what they're told but they feel
comfortable yeah right feel comfortable
with their sexuality and me having lived
in a family where anything sex related
was super shame and frowned upon it
really affected my ability to feel
comfortable sexuality when you grew up
in a culture and in a country where
that's the norm then your approach to
sex is very different does that make
sense so for me knowing what I like in
the bedroom and how I like to interact
with my partner
I don't like it when the girls just like
submissive like I'll just do what I want
whatever you want they don't know how to
feel comfortable and their sense of
sexuality it makes sex fun enjoyable for
me personally I like a woman when she
can assert herself so my general
experience from being when women have
grown up and lived and really been
centered in sexual repression is sex is
unenjoyable with them because they have
so much to deconstruct about themselves
a lot of it's like dating dating then
growing country with a lot of more steps
yeah it's a lot of stairs like no I will
not judge you I won't I don't give a
[ __ ] I mean let's go you know I mean so
did I get it I understand yeah seen it
in the way people from third world
countries sometimes they talk about it
and talk about is very different me
being from a third world country
my parents were I don't even understand
what my Harrison from mm-hmm cuz yes
they're Asian but in the weight that
like that the relationship I have my
parents now like I got talks about sex
with my parents hmm I'm gonna talk about
different [ __ ] with my parents and nice
okay that's good we're we're it's not
what I see with other people you know I
mean there's a little repression in his
law but I'll talk about that because you
know it's not God me and this and that
and that so it's really I don't know
it's it is crazy I see what you're
saying
I really see what you're saying
experience where you just know what
you're saying just talking with
different
yeah yeah it's like you know you know
like I'll make it a kid too okay maybe
not
I don't really thought this through but
here's my thing right I have friends
who'd be like B i'ma go to throw up
country and pick up a girl and I'm a
teacher everything and I'm always like
you can't teach a woman about being
comfortable or sexual that's not
something you can teach that's something
that she has to believe in it has to be
great it's like I know guys like yeah
I just need a girl who's gonna listen
cuz I'm a teacher how to suck dick I
will teach you how to suck my D
I'm like bro there are women who suck
dick and there are dick suckers and the
difference is everything
I cannot instruct a woman to suck my
dick to the point where it feels
unbelievable I can give her some
pointers where it feels better but to
have my dick sucked in a way that I like
Oh doing the damn thing you don't think
she has to love sucking dick yeah I mean
so so so think like a man that you know
there's some man
yes look there's some there's there's
some there's some man that Putin yeah
and I'm from qualifying yeah boom boom
eat ah yes yes yae boom boom yes I'm
Annie pom pom until you come here yes
ladies don't act like I'm crazy ladies
y'all ever had a dude and you just like
wondering is she gonna go down on me
right and you don't want to ask cuz it
sounds a little weird but you want to
poo poo mate but then finally he does do
it and it's kind of met and then there's
men who smashing you right and then in
the middle smash and they just pull up
your legs and they start you and you're
going alright you see ladies [ __ ]
having seizures right because men are
really enthusiastic about it I can't I
can't teach her girl to be that she got
to be comfortable and want to do it
there has to be LaHood auntie Wren you
have to be enthusiastic about the
process so for me I wouldn't go to some
place to train somebody you can't train
them but when you meet a girl who knows
what she doing yo like don't talk about
eating boom boom with a Jamaican accent
by carbide - up [ __ ] I here may not saw
[ __ ] no man I saw yeah you know what yo
I do yo man what happened that girl dick
suckers I'm talking about girls was just
like in the middle of kiss and just
jumped on the knees and pull my dick out
of the Jean whole like didn't even do
under the button he undid the zipper and
all right like waking up in the middle
of the night waking up in the middle of
the night and my dick is in her mouth
I'm like holy [ __ ]
is this a dream because if it's reality
no see there are some people who be
doing some things I could never teach
you that kind of skill set you've got to
be you got to be enthusiastic because if
there's thews ii Azzam then there's
repetition
there's effort there's improvement and
there's creativity amen facts big facts
that's all fat some facts
it taught because you're not going down
on the the best top I thought talking
[ __ ] here's what okay men have three
levels of orgasm okay
there's level one which is your regular
orgasm right you can get that normally
from penetration or you can get it from
masturbating it's when you pop up and it
feels good in its chill buns Monique
okay
then there's level zero orgasm okay
level zero is when you bustin up but
there's literally zero chemical reaction
and you liked it something came out but
nothing happened that's a penny [ __ ]
maybe it's a penny wink a Betty but pay
nuts no to me it's like opening a Kinder
Surprise and there's no president said
Betty not my shirt okay when you watch
porn and then you know the crazy yeah I
met two that I wasted on that yeah yeah
there's just some nuts that just nothing
happens okay but then there's level two
there's level two nuts okay
now level two happens generally the only
way I've been able to experience level
two is when a girl's blowing alright
and I remember the first time I had a
level two [ __ ] I swear to God I swear
my mother's like I didn't know what was
happening I felt something was coming
but I wasn't ready so I remember I
started I started holding on to the pen
like I was just like oh my god brace for
impact and brother I swear my mother's
life I was like I started panicking
because this girl was doing her thing
you know I mean he's going crazy right
and I started to panic cuz I'm like
what's happening right now and I thought
I was peeing I thought I was peeing in
her mouth but this girl didn't flip she
was just taking it right and I'm like oh
my god she peeing right now what the
[ __ ] is happening
thank God my mom not watching this she
swallowed okay
she swallowed right and in my head I'm
like oh my god
this girl likes pee I thought I came so
hard I thought this girl like piss bro
okay so I'm there I'm like right and I'm
just in bed like duh and I waited to see
I remember looking at her face just to
see if like she was gonna yell at me for
peeing in her mouth
and she did it and so a day later I
realized I just had a crazy orgasm and
she didn't like P so then I became
really enthralled it's getting good time
but all this to say that's a level two
level two is unbelievable level two is
unbelie-- level two is what we call when
a man says next level they're talking
about level two when when you come from
a woman giving you top that's a level
two and this is their level three I
don't know I listen I hope not
my [ __ ] might fall off okay because
level two is crazy enough as it is so
yeah there's three levels that's as far
as I know I've never heard of level
three you know who knows what you have
to do so that's there is a level three
[ __ ] level three spiritual business
if you don't get the [ __ ] up out of here
talking about our chakras aligned with
your yoga [ __ ] can push a drinkin ass
you're [ __ ] gay level three aspire
vibration shut the [ __ ] yeah yeah level
threes prostate no no trust me I've
definitely done the prostate stuff it's
not levels okay I'm sorry prostate is
great but it's it's a level one point
five level two is normally from [ __ ]
and that's just crazy
you smell curry green wheat yeah nah nah
so that's it for our sex talk I got very
intense very fast all right let's see
let's go back here I think somebody
donated quick shoutout from London
Andrew Joyner don't always agree never
know what preachers on about but always
appreciate your input cool bands rose if
they're not send it on I said keep it up
bro so I appreciate you shows if I went
to high school with this guy this guy
was awesome yeah yeah he should do
really cool Kumail we also use come boo
bear because misapplication teacher you
say well bear
yes you wouldn't say Robert he would say
yeah
do y'all want kids preach yeah yeah
that's a change for you cuz you know a
lot of times you always want kids
because before I felt like you're never
saying this to make your sight she's
never said it'd be good I was like I
don't like I don't want kids right now
when I say I don't want two kids right
now it's like it's not like I don't want
two kids never yeah I'm in a better
place where I know that I've ever been
you know what I mean so yeh like I don't
I didn't want kids before because
because I couldn't mm-hmm I like money
too much right now you don't like money
as much I got more money hmm
this is different I'm in a different
predicament mentally I'm different
let me just eat what I want kids I'm all
for gonna be like yeah well you know
you're never gonna be ready for kids
shut the [ __ ] up yes yes there could be
a time are you ready for kids
hmm and I'm all moves I'm almost yeah I
was there mmm you want it yeah yeah I
want lots of kids I want like eight nine
kids yeah so I might have to baby lumps
Maya Chad how many kids I just said it
Maya Chad earlier said I became is
probably not that good I mean maybe
maybe my own Maya chat [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
no no that's a different girl those two
my love uh you know listen I'm not gonna
rape my sex kills the people I'm with
enjoy so that's all that matters to me I
don't mean to brag to everybody else so
Me's like it's between me and the person
I'm intimate with if you think I might
be trend that's okay well you might be
trash maybe there's some people to
something like I'm sure I've definitely
given some nature I'm definitely giving
some lambdak
there's been a couple games some lame
[ __ ] - yeah I mean you can't hit always
that's like even Kobe has Maya Chad who
you noticed
[ __ ] just doing it for them [ __ ]
clap [ __ ] oh you noticed me [ __ ] out of
here
even Kobe got some off nights anybody
anybody that's a Chan handsome so
everyone's gonna have some off nights
[Music]
let's see hey guys what happened to your
reddit I read it's still there from what
I know I don't haven't checked on it
unfortunately just don't keep up with
the reddit I'm not a big redditor so I
don't know how to do it and I don't make
enough room
unfortunately what percentage of your
audience is men women how old are you
guys I think it's like 70/30 70/30 or 75
on Instagram it is actually 43 16 women
women men yeah when we first started out
we were mostly women and then obviously
my misogyny came out and then the ladies
left beef broth deep and of course my
gayness came out I guess yeah and once
they found out preachers taking married
or potentially gay they all go and they
found out I'm the only single one and
I'm misogynistic that's it you are
thinking the question mm-hmm do you guys
still dance yes like I said check out
the Instagram I mean I need to dance
yeah you've got dance I've got a dance
this you guys should invite your best
friend me in love oh that's the girl who
leaves above all my solving yeah for
what
here we go but I do many questions just
one piece y'all know about men being
test stars huh yeah people question the
checks in those decent money and you
can't just read it up Abba shut up I
want to hear you ready good news gonna
be good
what's the worst place y'all have ever
traveled to I've just traveled to great
places
there's no what's the worst one out of
all of them you get to pick one no I
don't what's the worst place I've ever
been to
I'll think about it and maybe it'll come
to me Dominican Republic because of our
hu my people hmm
do you guys feel your content has
changed recently no huh not recently I
think we've been on it we just do it
more often I think we're getting better
at it though something's wrong ABBA why
the hate for bachata oh [ __ ] I don't
even know there's a leg but Santa
I hate [ __ ] other butts up us all right
but it's not incitement angry but I
thought merengue for me isn't that the
same level professing music yeah like no
lyrics in bachata are just gross if you
like to understand it and then I just
hate the slow rhythm and I hate dancing
that close with the ladies was like it
just bores me
I came here to party not the [ __ ]
here's some guy talked about how he
[ __ ] his best friend's girlfriend how
his best friend [ __ ] his below for any
he wants to die yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
everybody wants to commit suicide in
bachata necessarily not party music yeah
do you maybe zone by some morons getting
tired because the people are getting
creepy you think man are being creepy
fair women are creepy how can you tell
if someone is fake just look at them
yeah what do you mean just look at them
what I mean just look at them howdy
howdy do you know what it is the
Kryptonite of a liar someone has a good
memory
well thinking of someone is that is
hipergator fate you know I mean good
memory
yeah you see it as a boy hmm ABBA do you
dislike most women
type these questions later yes he does
he does Oh what do you know you don't
know of course not do I dislike most
women why do you think I dislike most of
it well that I understand why people
think you're a misogynistic the same way
I understand what these some people
think I'm gay come in sure I guess you
know I mean they think I am but it's
because you think you're mrs. anything
because of what their understanding of
what misogyny is right that's fair
should doctors be allowed to reject
people who ignore social distancing
guidelines that's a tough one that's a
good question how can you prove that oh
yeah how would the doctor prove that
this person what have they told them I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm going to church
and I'm touching everybody cuz I'm fine
I'm covered by Jesus and I understand
yeah Jesus blood yeah should a doctor
have to treat people who were covered
with Jesus semen
that's a good question I don't know the
answer I'll be honest with you you got
me stumped you have me stumped
listen I think no can I be a moderator
no attached so you can't try to pick
listen I'm trying to look for one why do
you think why do they think you are gay
preach because of some of the mannerism
that I have sometimes I'm like that you
know listen people have been calling me
gay my whole life my whole life because
that is the way that you can actually
hurt a man mm-hmm
emasculate him so and I've never been
afraid of that I've never been afraid
I'm is like I know
what I like you know bad [ __ ] is the
only thing that I like you know I mean
like I know what I like so I know I'm
not but he is it's the thing that it's a
regular thing it's just because I
knowing what I like because of a guy
that wax
I like voguing I like all of that [ __ ] I
mean but to some people being Dean yeah
they can't handle that like ya know that
already just that's a way to hurt
someone if you want to get someone's
that attention or if you want to hurt
someone that's how you gonna you're
gonna emasculate that person you're
gonna mess with the men right funny
thing is yeah a lot of man like yeah
it's more [ __ ] guinness muffled gate
but a lot of women a lot of women are
saying that as well because they mask
you later yeah I mean yeah Abba why do
you sit tastes so strange when you're
sleeping people like post noise I was
there a youtuber you'd like to
collaborate with and yes yes in who and
why well I already character to a
library double Chamblee yep yeah
destiny let go yeah do you ever tour and
if so will you do so in Minneapolis I
love your content thank you to our
layers we would that's a very French
name this new life goes on there's a lot
of there's a lot of there's a lot of
levels yeah there's a lot of French
names in the States because of either
the Louisiana or Frank people that win
now south well that goes beyond his
friendship that's a very French name
right yes you probably called herself
black horse here but yeah knuckles yeah
hmm advice for how to get level to top
be it I don't know what to tell you the
girls either got it or she don't like
listen you don't tell it by the way she
uses her hands on the dick listen the
evidence of good top is always how women
use their hands do you like dick or you
don't
now they can like it and still not take
it no they could
liking the living for the day even if
they live for it even if they live for
I'm telling you from experience this
doesn't matter even if they live for
they could have all the enthusiasm or if
they don't know how to use their hands
during a blow job
[ __ ] is [ __ ] over and some women
I can't tell me like I can't show them
how so
they gotta know how to use their hands
when they sucking dick I can't
they gotta use their hands hmm like
women think they just usually about the
whole time I'm like [ __ ] your mouth
only gonna do so much from where your
hand game at yo take that [ __ ] like it's
a lollipop no just like oh just like
around your back she like it's a
lollipop hmm and golf that she like
there's a remedy you know I mean like
you miss the remedy yeah I don't would
y'all collab with Caleb city I mean he
does mostly sketches so no but he does
cool [ __ ] what is the toughest place
you've ever traveled to the toughest
good boy New Orleans
why because they just had some real
[ __ ] over there and I could feel a lot
of tension like yeah New Orleans that
was the place where I felt like had the
most darkness and I'm not talking with
the people mm-hmm yeah
was it post Katrina you know that place
was like the murder capital of the
state's real long done it was it postage
treatment yep have y'all have some of my
stimulus money what I look like the
government guys that have so much
stimulus money that's hilarious absol my
son with me cuz he donated does okay
good well we'll have it I mean you don't
have to give it all this but thank you
very much
a Marvel 15 that's on you then a buff
every woman is different no that's on
them sometimes you have to show people
like [ __ ] I cannot show you I'm sorry
there's certain things you can't teach
certain things that cannot be learnt
they gotta be innate
all right now you can DJ little be
whatever what else I was thinking what
you said I can believe it
New Orleans is that one yeah New Orleans
is for real nearly is my favorite city
in the states I love the south and worth
a glass of PS PlayStation every time
place it just has better exclusives so
let's just mush it but I don't play
video games like I used to but that's my
[ __ ] you want an application about how
do you shave your pupule
how do you become funny if you're dusty
the two don't have anything to do with
them job you can be done something dusty
[ __ ] funniest [ __ ] some of the
best comedians are dusty muffled what is
none of your [ __ ] business
Wow alright I feel like the questions
are starting to die out how big are you
both Down Under
awesome my dick is always wanna know
about dicks they see it we gain but
these are some gay ass [ __ ] like
honestly some always some gangsters
alright these questions are trying it
alright I think I'm done with the
questions anything you want to bring up
to the fence nah we're good now 55 yeah
yeah I think I think that's it for me
cuz these questions are [ __ ] wack so
next time we come back y'all better do
better
Wow alright y'all better do better yeah
I don't see anything that interesting
look at me I'll drop any questions baby
see so you guys aren't already
subscribed to the Instagram page because
we do have an Instagram or repost
exclusive content
you got my see me dance you might see
preach dance you might see some other
[ __ ] so go check it out
what does happen preachers Abba atlas
Abba thoughtless and there's Eric
Walters preach dimples as BR e AC HD
and plz that's right so that's it guys a
lot of the questions you guys are asking
right now you guys can probably see they
were already answered so scroll back
that's it for today you guys have been
fun and we will come back with another
video tomorrow subscribe to the patreon
that's right